We've been talking over the last couple of
weeks about this new wave of very radical
and also extraordinarily ignorant, I mean
completely vapid on policy, Trumpy and members
of Congress, the three we've been focusing
on are Marjorie Taylor Greene, Lauren Bobert
and Madison Cawthorn.
And the last 24 to 48 hours have been an absolute
disaster for Marjorie Taylor Green to the
point that now Democrats are considering mechanisms
to expel her from Congress.
And even Republicans really should be thinking
about how do we distance from this absolutely
outrageous radical to new, not new to videos
have now come to light.
And in one of these videos, I'm sure many
of you remember the tragic and and completely
disheartened.
I don't even know what the word is to use
for the unconscionably tragic shooting at
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas High School in Parkland,
Florida.
And you may remember this activist, David
Hogge, who was a student at the time that
the school was a victim to that mass shooting.
There is video of Marjorie Taylor Green essentially
harassing David Hogg, following him on the
streets.
This was first reported back in June of last
year.
It is, again, going viral.
And I'm going to play the video in its entirety
for you.
This is this is Marjorie Taylor Green, a full
grown woman following David Hogg around Washington,
DC, harassing him.
David, why are you supporting the red flag
laws?
If there had been if Scott Peterson, the resource
officer at Parkland, had done his job, then
Nicholas Cruz would have.
Anybody in your high school or at least protected
that?
Why are you supporting read my gun laws that
attack our Second Amendment rights, and why
are you using kids to get as a barrier?
Do you not know how to defend your stance?
Look, I'm an American citizen, I'm a gun owner,
I have a concealed carry permit.
I carry a gun for protection for myself.
And you are using your lobby and the money
behind it and the kids to try to take away
my Second Amendment right.
You don't have anything to say for yourself.
I can't defend your stance.
How did you get over 30 appointments with
senators?
How do you do that?
How did you get major press coverage on this
issue?
And how did you get kids?
Why do you kid why kids go to school in small
towns were protected by with security guards,
with guns.
There would be no mass shootings at school.
That's why it's with a big guy with a gun.
Yet you're exactly right.
But.
We have nothing to say, no words, so I'm walking.
Nothing to say that he has nothing to say
because there really isn't anything to say.
You guys, he has nothing to say because he's
paid to do this.
Yes.
The walk away march.
He's got the he's got the women's march and
they're funding all of this.
Every town, gang, USA, they're funding all
the stuff.
OK, that was David Hook right there.
David, we saw him inside the Senate building.
He had 30, 30 appointments where he went around
and got to talk to senators.
I got to talk to none.
None.
He had media coverage all over the place.
I had zero.
Guess what?
I'm a gun owner.
I'm an American citizen, and I have nothing.
But this guy with his George Soros funding
and his major liberal funding has got everything.
I want you to think about that.
That's where we are.
And he's a coward.
He can't say one word because he can't defend
his state.
And this is not the only video of Marjorie
Taylor Green harassing people that is now
sort of being revived.
Here is one of Marjorie Taylor Green before
she was elected.
This is February of twenty nineteen.
She showed up at the House of Representatives
and was walking around the halls with a Bible,
with the idea of finding Congresswoman Ellen
Omar and Rasheeda Talib to get them to retake
their oaths on a Bible rather than a Koran.
And you'll hear her talk incorrectly about
how the oath isn't valid if taken on a Koran,
which is just not true.
Here's that video they signed that they swore
in on the Koran.
Oh, we have the Bible.
We're going to talk about swearing and how
to swear in on the Bible with them and let
them know what our law says that you can't
swearing on the Koran.
So.
Right.
We're going explain that.
You know, we're going to explain about how
you can't swear in on the Koran and we're
going to have the Bible and ask them if they
would swear in on the Bible that we really
need to know.
Yes, we have the oath yet.
So I think it's important to say that thing
is now that you are in a relationship, which
is you shouldn't be infringing on our religion.
Yes.
By saying that we can't swear.
But when they swore in, it wasn't a lie yet.
Right.
So at the time, they swore, I don't know.
I think at the time they thought that that
was a pass because it wasn't the passing of
Republican control.
Yes.
So it was passed after they swore in.
So they're not really official?
I don't think so.
Let's go ask them the swearing in the Bible,
because like you said.
Well, I'm yeah.
In the Bible.
Well, the bottom line is the bottom line is
Sharia law is not compatible with America.
Yep.
That's the bottom of the Bible.
That's the bottom line.
How can you say you represent women but you
support Sharia law?
This is currently an elected official, not
just a low level elected official.
This is one of 435 members of the U.S. House
of Representatives.
And I don't care what happens to the Republican
Party in terms of unity or, you know, I hope
for the demise of the Republican Party.
I think that it would be no better thing than
Donald Trump launching this third party he's
reportedly thinking of and dividing the Republican
Party.
If the Republican Party has to fight off Trump's
party, the Patriot Party or whatever, it will
hopefully allow Joe Biden and Democrats and
the more progressive elements of the Democratic
Party to get things done.
That being said, if Republicans don't denounce
Marjorie Taylor Green's extremism, if they
don't denounce the absurdity of Lauren Bobert,
if they don't denounce the just vapid politics
of Madison Cawthorn, they're going to own
it now.
Maybe they're OK with that.
Maybe Republicans believe that they should
be going more in this direction rather than
going back to not that it was what I agreed
with, but more to the politics of people like
John McCain as an example or more in the direction
of someone like Mitt Romney.
But the Republican Party now has its it's
a contingent that I don't it's a conspiratorial,
paranoid fringe, radical element that was
not there before.
And there's been a lot of radical stuff.
I mean, listen, Louie Gohmert has been at
Matt Gates.
These people, these people are bonkers.
But this is sort of just taking it up to another
level.
I'm not saying anybody else is good.
I'm not saying I agree with Louie Gohmert.
I'm just saying this is another level of crazy.
And Marjorie Taylor Greene also.
Unfortunately for her, some Facebook posts
were uncovered were years ago she was talking
about killing Democrats.
And I think her defense is that lots of people
help her manage her page, basically saying
it wasn't me who actually posted it.
This is absolutely disgusting, depraved.
Stuff and for the sake of the Republican Party,
they should say this does not represent us
Democrats looking into how could she be expelled
from the House of Representatives?
I don't know how likely that is to happen,
but extraordinarily, extraordinarily disturbing
stuff